help I need money I got a question for
my newsletter readers love you guys my
den who wrote in and he he epitomizes a
lot of people who write in to me asking
me questions about starting the business
and raising capital so I wanted to help
out today so he was really wrote hi Evan
how you doing hope you're doing great in
this email I wanted to share the things
that I do and the problems that I'm
facing currently we run an IT company
which develops off for clients we have
an idea in terms of making money and
also making people's lives easier but
we're lacking capital and manpower we
can't move further we have one part-time
programmer
where we need to rely on here a hundred
percent charges are so high I have an
idea to venture the sugarcane business
or coffee business I know the market is
big but lacking capital and idea of how
about how to go about it I am really
bored working under other people please
advise hope to hear from you soon my Dan
okay so this is an important one this is
an important one because first of all it
sounds like you're just chasing the
dollars okay you're just chasing the
dollars trying to find whatever
opportunity will make you a lot of money
and that's what you're focusing and
maybe you hate your job you know you
don't like working for other people but
chasing the dollars alone is not gonna
help make it happen the reason why your
software company isn't hugely successful
isn't lack of money it's because this
isn't your passion right you can't start
a software development company if you
don't know software or if your business
partner doesn't know software you can't
have a company with one guy working
part-time who's not invested heavily
into your business look at successful
software development companies and look
at who the founders are there's always
somebody who is passionate about the
technology you need that person on board
if that's not you and you don't have a
business partner who's doing it then
that's not the business to be in
you got to be in something that you love
that you can contribute to you can
invest your time into your passion and
help people out with because it's not
going to work and it's the solution to
get more money to hire people the
solution is for you to focus your
efforts on something that where you can
add a lot of value to people's lives
right and then you're not focused you're
looking at
hurricane business coffee business where
none of these things none of these
things are taking off you need to focus
and you don't need a lot of money to do
it you just got to think how can I
invest my time to help people and to add
a lot of value you figure that out
you're on your path to make a lot of
money with the business I had a software
company I'm not a technical guy I was a
business development guy I was the
marketing guy but my two partners were
technical they were cutting the code we
had no cost I was making 300 bucks a
month that's how I got by at the start
this company doesn't have to cost you
anything and I know you hate working for
other people and hey you know what I do
too welcome to the world of
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship eclis
hate working for other people that's why
we go do our own thing that's why we
work why don't we brave all these crazy
hard conditions because we want to be
our own boss but having a good job can
be a path to starting your own business
so what I would recommend for you and
anybody in the same situation okay stop
thinking about the resources you don't
have stop thinking about the money you
don't have the team you don't have all
the stuff that you don't have so think
about what you do have and how to turn
that into something because that's what
entrepreneurs do we turn nothing into
something
focus your efforts and find the one
thing that you want to do with your life
that's gonna help people what is it is
it in sugar is it in coffee is it in
software is it something totally
different one thing that you're gonna
focus on for the next two years what is
that and if you don't have the money to
start it you could bootstrap anything
you could go you don't need money to
start any business you could find a way
to start with nothing but if you need
money to survive you can't you know pay
your rent and you know put food on the
table then go get a job where you can
learn where you have this vision of what
you want to do with your life the type
of company you want to build go work for
someone who's already done that thing
before and you know it's part-time its
temporary you know you're doing it for a
year for six months three months a month
whatever it is you're making some money
you're learning the ropes you get to
understand the industry you're making
some contacts you're making mistakes
while getting paid by somebody so when
you're ready to launch your business you
already know what you're doing you have
all the contacts you need you have all
the experience you need you could hit
the ground running that's the reason to
get a job
so focus man focus focus your energies
pick the one thing you're gonna do stop
worrying about the things you don't have
and do something amazing because it's in
you I see the passion there get started
believe you guys liked this video thumbs
up below let me know what you think
you're facing the same problem or you
overcame and recently put it in the
comments below I want to read about it
you have a question for me leave it
below I'll make a video response and
click on my face if you want to see more
videos like this to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon